sliska Christine is Germany's
northernmost state the only state with
two coastlines the Baltic to the east
with its endless white sand beaches and
the North Sea to the west fringed by the
Wadden sea when the tide is low the mud
flats seemed to reach the horizon there
a habitat for a rich biodiversity
another North Sea Island is Germany's
favorite party Island Zoot holiday
makers throng the beaches during the day
and pack the many clubs and bars at
night
GunStar on 50 will come from all over
Germany it's like one big family
immediately Yaffe guy come to compound
for vacation every year and they
celebrate together
we kind I'm not fayette the Baltic and
the North Sea are connected by the Kiel
Canal the world's most heavily traveled
artificial waterway it crosses about 100
kilometers of schleswig-holstein from
one spittle on the mouth of the Elbe to
the state capital Keon I come in here
while I'm here every year the city hosts
the International Kea regatta in June
about 3 million guests come to enjoy the
Tall Ships parade those looking for a
little less commotion should head to
hushed in Switzerland an uplands region
sculpted by the last ice age and dotted
with over 200 lakes one of the best
times to visit is when the canola is in
bloom
this isn't one of the many lakes it's an
arm of the Baltic called fish lie inlet
it reaches some 43 kilometers inland to
the city of Schleswig nearby is Hetty
boo an important trading settlement
during the Viking Age it recalls those
times in an open-air Museum in Budds a
Quebec historical fact gives way to
historical fantasy with the cowboys and
Indians of calm eyes popular Western
stories an open-air theater has been
staging The Adventures of Winnetou and
old shatterhand since 1952
better go please nobuta
pressed up against the Danish border is
Germany's northernmost city plentiful
known for its beer commonly called
Flint's we have all got it we need a
fresh bidder Pilsner to quench our
thirst especially when we're out on the
boats come on post
another city well worth a visit is
Lubeck the cultural capital of the north
it's old town is a beautifully preserved
historical site and like most cities
into a sleek wash done it's right on the
water
you